supongamos que tienes el presentimiento
de que el azúcar la azúcar de alguna
manera ocasiona enfermedades cardíacas
de alguna manera ocasiona enfermedades
cardíacas y quieres investigar esto
quisiera saber qué tipo de estudios
estadísticos pudieras realizar para
estimar qué tanta azúcar consume la
población y si esto está relacionado o
no con las enfermedades cardíacas
lo primero que podrías hacer es darte
una idea de cuál es el consumo de azúcar
de la población en general obviamente no
es posible no hay manera de saber el
consumo preciso de azúcar de cada uno de
los miembros suponemos que estamos en
méxico es imposible saber el consumo
diario de azúcar de cada uno de los 100
millones de mexicanos así es que para
darnos una idea del consumo de azúcar
necesitamos realizar un estudio de
muestreo así es que si aquí tenemos
nuestra población si aquí tenemos los
100 millones de mexicanos esta es
nuestra población vamos a tomar muestras
vamos a hacer muestreos usualmente son
muestras aleatoria
vas a tomar encuestas de gente que está
saliendo de una dulcería o de gente que
está saliendo de un gimnasio tomas una
muestra aleatoria en la cual cualquier
miembro de la población tiene la misma
probabilidad de ser incluido es por eso
que el lugar donde se tome la muestra no
debe de tener ninguna relación con el
consumo de azúcar así es que las
personas seleccionadas te indicarán
quizá a través de una encuesta cuánta
azúcar consumen diariamente en promedio
y así podrás generar entonces estos
datos obviamente entre más muestras se
tenga va a ser mucho mejor y abordaremos
esto en futuros vídeos de estadística
donde veremos que se obtiene una mejor
estimación del verdadero parámetro
poblacional a medida que se incrementan
el número de muestras pero aquí queremos
hacer esto para darnos una idea de cuál
es el consumo promedio de azúcar del
mexicano en un día normal así es que eso
que estamos haciendo aquí tomar muestras
aleatorias que básicamente estarían
generando una estadística que nos va a
permitir estimar el valor real del
parámetro que en este caso sería el
consumo diario de azúcar de los
mexicanos esto es lo que se llama un
estudio de muestra
estudio de muestreo el cual se insiste
nos permite estimar el consumo diario de
azúcar por parte de la gente pero tú
quieres ir más allá aquí solo obtienes
la estimación del consumo diario de
azúcar por parte de la gente y tú
quieres saber cómo se relaciona eso con
las enfermedades cardíacas
para esto decides entonces hacer una
encuesta decides realizar una encuesta y
preguntas sobre la cantidad de azúcar
que se ha consumido en cierto periodo
por supuesto la selección de personas
tiene que darse de manera aleatoria
así es que supongamos que decides tomar
una muestra aleatoria de personas de 60
años de edad de nueva cuenta no vas a
tomar la muestra en el hospital o la vas
a tomar en el gimnasio tienes que tomar
una muestra que sea aleatoria en lugares
cuyas actividades no afecten el
resultado de la muestra
supongamos entonces que realizas una
encuesta a 300 personas de 60 años de
edad y les preguntas cuál es el promedio
para el consumo de azúcar diario para
los últimos 30 años
y también las preguntas sobre el estado
de su corazón y lo que obtienes es algo
así digamos que en el eje x tienes el
consumo de azúcar y en el eje y tienes
el riesgo de enfermedad cardiaca podemos
ponerlo así como riesgo de enfermedad
cardíaca a los 60 y entonces la gráfica
se podría ver como esto y aquí
tendríamos por ejemplo alguien que
consume 200 gramos de azúcar por día por
decir algo que tiene un riesgo de
enfermedad cardiaca a los 60 alto pero
también podríamos encontrar a alguien
que tiene un riesgo de enfermedad
cardíaca a los 60 abajo con el mismo
consumo alto de azúcar y así podríamos
graficar todos estos puntos y ver que
aparentemente obviamente no voy a
graficar los 300 puntos pero de acuerdo
a lo que nos muestran los puntos
aparentemente hay una cierta correlación
podríamos intentar graficar una recta
representativa aunque aquí hay ciertos
valores perdidos pero aparentemente
aparentemente hay una recta que se
justa a la tendencia de los puntos aquí
podrías decir que aparentemente el
consumo de azúcar y el riesgo de
enfermedad cardiaca los 60 están
correlacionados van aparejados para
quien tiene un gran consumo de azúcar
hay un alto riesgo de enfermedad
cardiaca para quien tiene un bajo
consumo de azúcar el riesgo enfermedad
cardiaca es menor el estado de su
corazón es mejor ahora a menudo los
estudiantes de ciencias médicas al ver
esto podrían decir bien podemos
establecer que el azúcar un alto consumo
de azúcar ocasiona un alto riesgo de
enfermedades cardíacas pero eso es muy
peligroso pues estos datos no están
indicando que el azúcar eleve el riesgo
de enfermedad cardiaca podría ser al
revés que la gente que tiene un alto
riesgo de enfermedad cardiaca come
azúcar por ansiedad o pudieran ser que
hay muchísimas otras causas que están
ocasionando esto las cuales no estamos
viendo no sé que hay alguna otra
deficiencia que les está haciendo
requerir más azúcar no podemos
establecer con esto cómo es la relación
de casualidad es el consumo de azúcar el
que ocasiona una enfermedad cardíaca o
es al revés la enfermedad cardíaca es la
que está ocasionando un alto consumo de
azúcar
otro factor quizá un alto consumo de
grasas lo que ocasiona la enfermedad
cardiaca y quien consume mucha grasa
también consume mucha azúcar quién sabe
aquí lo único que estamos viendo es que
hay correlación este de aquí se llama
estudio observacional puedes observar la
relación pero no puedes establecer qué
es lo que está causando que déjame
escribir esto aquí este es un estudio
observacional estudio observacional tú
te puedes preguntar entonces cómo
podríamos determinar si efectivamente el
azúcar es la causa de la enfermedad
cardíaca para eso tienes que realizar un
experimento
un experimento y para hacer un estudio
experimental necesitas contar con dos
grupos de personas uno de ellos es tu
grupo experimental déjame hacerlo mejor
con un círculo es un grupo de personas
digamos de 100 personas aquí sería tu
grupo experimental y el otro sería tu
grupo de control tu grupo de control y
lo que tienes que hacer si deseas hacer
este tipo de experimento y como veremos
este tipo de experimento quizás no se
podría realizar pues muchas personas lo
considerarían falto de ética yo lo
considero falto de ética pero lo que
harías en este estudio es asignar
aleatoriamente adultos de digamos 30
años los asignas de manera aleatoria en
uno de estos dos grupos de nueva cuenta
cuando decimos de manera aleatoria no
quieres poner los sanos en un solo grupo
y los enfermos en el otro grupo o
viceversa tiene que ser aleatorio no
quieres poner gente un solo estrato
social o demográfico en un solo grupo
haces entonces una asignación aleatoria
de las personas a estos grupos y en el
grupo experimental tú modificas una
variable en este caso la variable que
nos interesa es
a azúcar se podía establecer entonces
que a todas las personas de este grupo
además de su consumo usual de azúcar
todas las noches deberán de tomar no sé
una taza de jarabe o establecer
diariamente un consumo mínimo de azúcar
básicamente lo que estamos haciendo es
aumentar la ingesta de azúcar aumentar
la ingesta de azúcar en este grupo lo
cual no lo estamos haciendo en el otro
grupo y por eso decíamos que es poco
ético aumentar el consumo de azúcar para
las personas de este grupo lo cual es
dañino para la salud y así después de un
largo periodo de tiempo
digamos 30 años cuando los sujetos del
estudio tienen 60 años de edad y
evaluarse entonces en qué condición se
encuentra el corazón de los sujetos del
grupo experimental si han sufrido algún
ataque al corazón algún infarto lo que
se va a evaluar aquí es si las
diferencias en el estado del corazón de
los sujetos del grupo experimental son
significativas estadísticamente y
podríamos suponer que es debido al
azúcar o no por el contrario las
diferencias se ocasionaron únicamente
debido a la sal por ejemplo si existe
esto y te das cuenta que el riesgo de
los sujetos del grupo experimental de
sufrir una enfermedad cardiaca es
ligeramente mayor que el día
que presentan los sujetos del grupo de
control bueno si bien el experimento se
llevó correctamente no podríamos
concluir que esto es debido al consumo
de azúcar pues una diferencia pequeña
puede darse debido únicamente al azar
por el contrario si después de 30 años
este grupo tiene 10 veces un mayor
riesgo de enfermedades cardiacas o ha
tenido diez veces una mayor incidencia
de ataques al corazón entonces tendrías
argumentos estadísticos de que este
grupo experimental de 100 personas tiene
10 veces más riesgo de contraer
enfermedades cardíacas con respecto a
este grupo de control pues una
diferencia tan grande no puede ser
debida únicamente al asad entonces
estaríamos convencidos de nuestra
conclusión de que la ingesta de azúcar
es lo que lo está ocasionando en fin ya
profundizaremos en estos tres tipos de
estudio pero la idea de este vídeo es
que te des cuenta que si bien existe una
gran variedad de aplicaciones de la
estadística es el contexto en el que se
dan estas aplicaciones lo que va a
determinar el tipo de estudio este es
para estimar el parámetro real de la
población cuál es el consumo real de
azúcar de la población creas una muestra
usar los datos de esa muestra para
obtener un estadístico que te va a
permitir estimar el parámetro de la
población
un estudio observacional observas lo que
está sucediendo el consumo de azúcar
contra el riesgo de enfermedad cardíaca
puedes decir mira hay una relación vale
la pena hacer un experimento sobre esto
porque solo a través de un experimento
se puede intentar establecer una
relación de causalidad